[Music]
I'm Stephen Wiltshire hi dude joins
Stephen is an artist who creates
incredibly intricate drawings of
cityscapes I love drawing tool buildings
tools skyscrapers skylines street scenes
and he does this entirely from memory
when Stephen was three he was diagnosed
as autistic he was completely mute and
lived entirely in his own world
early on Stephens teachers noticed he
loved to draw he had found his way to
connect with others Stephen has the
ability to look at a subject once and
then draw an accurate and detailed
picture of it including panoramas of
entire cities based off just a quick
look I'll go up on their helicopter and
then memorize it and then after being on
a helicopter and straight back at the
hotel and then starts to talk his
incredible talent launched an artistic
career that has taken him around the
world
Los Angeles Dubai Houston Texas
and Tokyo in Japan and that's just to
name a few
New York's my favorite Empire State
Building Chrysler Building and there
lots of yellow New York taxicabs and
steven has no plans of stopping anytime
soon
someone told me that people like me
joints feel good always being happy
about it
[Music]
I can see someone I knew as a child and
immediately recognize them as an adult
or I can see someone who worked at a
store that I used to go to ten years ago
and see them on the street and recognize
them is that Clerk my name is Jennifer
Jarrett and I'm a super recognizer
I remember just about every face I see I
don't have to have an emotional
attachment to people to remember them I
really started to recognize it when I
went to college I would meet people I
would always remember them and then a
couple of months later I'd be at a party
and people would say oh do you two know
each other and I'd say yes and the other
person would say no so then I sort of
started to learn what was a memorable
encounter and what wasn't
in terms of being a super recognizer so
far I haven't really found any way to
utilize it at my last college reunion
my friends were so excited because you
know everybody worries that they're
gonna go to a reunion and not remember
who people are so people were sticking
to me like glue so I could tell everyone
who was in the room
[Music]
imagine remembering every single day of
your life all in perfect detail for
those with highly superior
autobiographical memory or H Sam for
short this is their reality I remember
everything that's personally happened to
me since I was born
that's Rebecca sharukh I was fascinated
by this condition so I called her up to
find out more hi Rebecca
hi how are you going I'm doing all right
it's very wet Saturday morning here how
are you going side note in this moment I
just realized Rebecca will remember that
this day was a wet morning forever so
you remember everything in great detail
people can remember what they did last
Saturday but I can remember what I did
Saturday 10 years ago what about a
memory from when you out of the baby
when I was 12 days old I was lying down
on the fur car seat in my parents car
and I was staring up at the steering
wheel and I thought what is that Rebecca
is one of only 60 people worldwide to
have been identified with having hate
sin all through my teenage years I
thought that everybody remembered in
this kind of way I thought it was
completely normal it wasn't until she
was 21 when her parents decided to
submit her to the University of
California to undergo two years of
testing after this she was officially
identified as having H Sam since
memories can come to mind unexpectedly
any time of day a negative memory like
this can make living with HCM difficult
mum was porting me in
this Ichi satin dress and I was crying
because I didn't like it and mum gave me
this Minnie Mouse toy and I couldn't say
anything at the time but her face
terrified me but on most days eh Sam as
a gift
Rebecca can recall happy memories and
moments when times get tough but good
memory it makes me so thankful about
having this kind of patience and memory
thanks for chatting Rebecca yep
[Music]
let's say you're in London you need to
get from the London Eye to Buckingham
Palace taxi please we would leave one
hour right Belvedere Road left [ __ ]
chilli street oh wait you know the whole
group already what we have to all London
black cab drivers have to have completed
their knowledge we need to know all the
straights of modes in London to provide
that service okay let's go see with the
Queen lips
[Music]
London is famous for its black taxis you
need to get to somewhere no sweat
because every black cabbie has to pass
an insanely hard test known as the
knowledge like this guy hello my name is
Peter Allen up in your London taxi
driver for nine years
okay all the knowledge is the test that
you have to pass in order to become a
London taxi driver it's the toughest
taxi test in the world the first thing
you have to do is learn what's called
the blue book as a cab driver it's your
Bible you have to learn 320 routes
around London so that's six hundred and
forty quarter of a mile areas you have
to learn 25,000 streets and roads within
a six-mile radius or two Fabri Square in
London you have to learn every single
point of interest place of interest
apartment building housing the stylee
station lost synagogue is a few moments
later why furniture shop I want to show
it club our restaurant everything anyway
aware of pain passion you might want to
go okay then let's go to the exam center
my name is Katie channels and I'm the
knowledge of London manager so the exams
are several phases of all appearances
it's basically an interview type
situation where you describe the streets
and roads attempting to use the shortest
distance between point a and point B at
the beginning we might ask them the name
of a theater where that theater is and
by the end of their knowledge with it
expect them to know boys actually
showing at that theater what on average
it takes 2 to 4 years to learn the
knowledge the best way to study is to go
out onto the streets on a scooter
isn't that right at us my name is a bass
actor you'd be studied knowledge for
about four and a half years now
and my next appearance is in about three
weeks time it's like a full-time job you
wake up in the morning go out on your by
a couple of hours come to the college
study study study here sit while
sleeping and studying as well yeah one
in five who attempt the knowledge
actually pass that's the same success
rate as the US Navy SEAL
GPS and Sat Navs are banned in the exam
but why not use them on the streets my
GPS is here and if we get somewhere and
we see a roads closed we need to say
right that's closed but I know if I go
left here that would
take me there I'll go right here that
would take me there we need to be able
to do all that as well as having a
conversation with the person in the back
and solving the world problems at the
same time Leicester Square to Big Ben
please so you'd leave Leicester Square
by Irving straight to Charing Cross
there are 43 quintillion possible
combinations now imagine you have no
websites no books and no one to show you
how to solve it because you invented it
but you didn't invent the rubik's cube
this guy did
my name is anaerobic was born here in
this beautiful city of Budapest it was
1974 30 year-old Erno Rubik was just
beginning his career in academia I was
lecturing design and architecture very
similar in age with the students
ambitious to find new ways to teach them
especially about space and three
dimension
I made a cube as a teaching gate and for
my son to learn something from it once
the physical cube was put together
ernõ began hunting for its secrets and
the question was not it is possible to
solve it but the question was it is
possible to find a method to do that
there is 26 small cubes it looks the
same but in the structure of the cube
they have different rules
ernõ racked his brain first strategy
twisting and turning the cube in his
hands and his head to unlock his
creation after I started to understand
the nature of this actual movement I
found a way for a solution it's not that
straight way and after a month he
cracked the code but the story doesn't
end there
I had the feeling the potential of the
object I found it very simple to
manufacture and the result of that it
can be an object what is available for
everyone in 1980 Erna would finally
bring his cube to the world and from
there it took off becoming one of the
best-selling toys of all time because of
the content of the cube the world
discovered is not a gadget it's
something that is more valuable more
long life and after almost 40 years
Rubik's Cube has seen a comeback with
hundreds of competitions every year
across the world for ernõ the cube that
bears his name is more than just a toy
it's a reminder to never give up there
is always a way for a solution at all
their way to find something else
something new something different or
find the result of you if today is not
everything is good it doesn't mean to
can not be better depend on you
[Music]
you